thank you all for coming to our
theoretically speaking seminar series
which highlights exciting the advances
in computer science and related fields
for a broad general audience and I'm
Shafi Goldwasser and the director of the
Symons Institute for theory of computing
which was established in 2012 through a
gift from the Simons Foundation and we
are located on Berkeley campus at Calvin
Hall and dedicate the collaborative
research where we gather world experts
from all over the world to work on
specific topics in collaboration mostly
through our computer science and people
again in the sciences in engineering and
so and when I say sciences I mean very
broadly defined in social sciences
economics philosophy as well as the life
science and exact sciences and our
speaker tonight which is the main event
is Helen Helen Nissenbaum who was a
professor of information science at
Cornell Tech she previously served as
the associate director of the center for
human values at Princeton University
so Helen really really isn't it's a
great example for what we're trying to
do in the Simon's Institute bring our
guests and they will come and work in
the Institute not just in theoretical
science proper but also people who can
contribute to the field from other
disciplines in Helen holds a PhD in
philosophy from Stanford University and
a BA from the University of wits am I
saying it correctly and what else her
work spans societal ethical political
dimensions of information technology and
digital media her books she's published
several books include obfuscation a
user's guide for privacy and protest
values at play in digital games and
privacy in context technology policy
integrity of social life and she's
contributed to privacy enhancing
software including track me not in ed
nauseam which i think is part of the
topic of the lecture today and both are
free and available online so please join
me in welcoming Helen
[Applause]
before I start my presentation this talk
I do want to say thank you so much to
shafy to the Symons Institute to the
privacy program for including me in the
program the semester I had a sabbatical
half sabbatical coming up and I wanted a
place where I could you know get on and
do a lot of work and I also was
interested in stimulation and learning
and the Symons Institute just provides
the best of both as well as just very
comfortable setting so thank you so much
and I'm delighted to have the
opportunity to talk about this work ad
nauseam and data obfuscation some of you
may know maybe some of you have already
heard me talking about Office Keshan
it's something that I've been working on
for many years and I care a lot about it
and it remains an ongoing you could say
passion maybe even an obsession some of
you will probably realize and and I'm
really pleased to have the opportunity
to speak I have a hope they'll be I mean
there will be some time for discussion
and I'm always open to critique
suggestions and most of all people who
will join this particular let's call it
a struggle
now before I before I start with the
substance they're people who I want to
mention and have have you look at the
slide for a few minutes because I could
not have done most almost all maybe all
of what I'm going to be talking about
tonight if it weren't for these people
and you'll see I'll be mentioning them
as we we go along but they are a
critical part of what we've been trying
to do with data office Kesha and the
many others I should say are not only
colleagues who have worked on
obfuscation and with us on obfuscation
but with the various products that I'm
going to be describing to you
just contributed by sending us messages
and correcting the code and finding bugs
and so forth so if you only have a
minute and you're going to leave the
room and after this slide this is this
is this is and and otherwise known as an
outline of the talk that I'm about to
give this is what I want to achieve
during this talk first of all to explain
what I what we mean by data obfuscation
to show and admit that it is a
disruptive approach to asserting privacy
to asserting privacy rights and also
expressing protest against some of
what's going on today with surveillance
but it's also a very very natural
reaction the second point is that it's a
fragile approach it's contingent and
it's circumstantial it's very hard to
come up with some grand scheme or grand
theory of data obfuscation because how
well it works is very contingent upon
details of the circumstance which I
think unfortunately removes me a little
bit outside of theory which maybe demand
something much more general nevertheless
I argue it should be guarded as a
powerful chip in the grand bargain for
fair and adequate privacy regulation I
hope and it's my wish that it should be
scientifically studied that it can be
can be refined and developed and I use
the word Savior I know it's a little bit
grand in these increasing numbers of
adversarial settings that we find
ourselves in in which data is being
grabbed from us and used in ways that we
don't even know about and not
necessarily ways that serve our
interests and finally that if there's
anyone in the audience who wants to
build systems that others get we need a
lot more instance
so let me start and this is back in 2000
and let's say 2005 2006 was track me not
which was the first effort of data
obfuscation and I was I was at that time
a few years before 2006 I was part of a
large NSF grant which involved mainly
computer scientists and I was you know
the representative ethicist in this
large privacy grant and I remember it
was just about the time where arewell
had released its anonymized search query
set and it was also roughly about the
time that the Department of Justice was
trying to generate regulation around
child children's privacy copper and they
want to do so there was an effort by the
DOJ to show that there was a lot of
pornography online and that there was a
lot of activity of people using search
engines to find pornography so they went
to the various search companies and they
said you know show us the queries show
us the results of the queries some of
the search engines complied they
partially complied some of you may
recall that google fought back and said
that they weren't going to complain of
entually they gave some attenuated set
of search query terms so that was the
big thing going on I think many people
perhaps some of the the cryptographers
and theoretical computer scientists here
and elsewhere were very excited by the
fact that you could take a so-called
anonymized data set but even in New York
Times journalist was able to take this
anonymize AOL data set and then actually
identify and I won't go into the details
of that but actually the whole idea of
anonymization and and the difficulty of
anonymizing data sets in this way is
crucial to the privacy program and many
people in the program but but that's you
know I was on this little ditra and when
I heard about these things
I remember we were at a retreat I was
complaining I was saying wow you know
what that tells me that such companies
are actually storing every search I make
and isn't that outrageous I don't want
them to have my search terms and my
computer science colleagues looked at me
kind of pityingly and they said yeah
well of course the search terms are
going to the you know Google or AOL god
knows which search engines were
available in those days and and of
course it's in the server they have the
search term it's there's there's nothing
you can do about it
and I was obstinate and I thought well
yeah maybe there is nothing that I can
do about it
to remove the search terms but what if I
could mess with the search terms and I
spoke to a student who was Daniel Howard
who was a PhD student at NYU at the time
and we decided that even though we
couldn't remove the search terms what we
could do is generate false search terms
and thus Trackman art was born and we we
created an extension of browser
extension which generated fake query
terms and this we released the first
version in 2006 we've been updating it
ever since and I should say update
improve we the note the noise that we
generate is better and looks like this
and you have you have some ability to
personalize it to which searches you
wanted to go to it works with a lot
works you you know I could have chosen
by do but since I I don't use by do I I
hadn't selected it as one of my choices
you can have this query the query
frequency and and so forth and by now
regenerating we're pulling the terms
from RSS feeds and many complaints there
were many complaints from people who who
wanted to have some
crawl about the search terms and so we
allow people to choose what RSS feeds to
choose from so that happened by now
thirteen years later the person who is
maintaining this single-handedly is
Vincent to be honor who's a technologist
with at this point with our SEP in Paris
and that's the equivalent of the US
federal trade sorry federal
communicating the FCC the Federal Trade
Commission and there's a lot of ongoing
work because the browsers are updated
and so forth and we have to deal with
various side channel attacks and this is
ongoing work for for Vincent and your
fingers crossed he does this as a labor
of love but as we were working on track
me not it occurred to all of us and to
myself that there's something one can
generalize yeah we we roughly we roughly
estimate about 50,000 daily you know
daily users we don't keep close enough
track and you can download it from lots
of different places and so we have the
numbers that Mozilla gives us and maybe
maybe we know the chrome users as well
but but I asked Vincent this question
and that was his estimate we realized
that office kesshun is a technique it's
a technique it's not just a one-off
thing and so we we started thinking
about what are the characteristics of
obfuscation could we define our
discussion in a more general way so one
here's one way to think about
obfuscation if you want to protect
privacy and you have many of course
cryptographic techniques you want to
protect Waldo in a
cryptographic way there were a couple of
students at NYU and they had created
this little system with me called
cryptograph cryptogram would as you see
blur photographs let's say you you could
use it for your Facebook album but
Facebook also used to blur your photos
except from the Facebook perspective
they could see your photos and so we
wanted some way for people to be able to
blur their programs
sorry their photographs on the Facebook
server and these two students had come
up with cryptogram but if you want to
office gate if you want to achieve
privacy through obfuscation this is how
you do it
so the definition that and and some time
within that period I had I wrote a book
with fan Branton
who is he's now on the faculty at NYU in
the media culture and communications
apartment at the time that this work was
happening Finn was a postdoc with me and
he was an amazing resource because he
knows so much and when he heard about
Trackman art he kept on coming up and
say oh that reminds me of this and that
reminds me of that so he wrote this book
and in that we defined obfuscation as
production inclusion etc of ambiguous or
false dead and an effort to evade
distract confused data gatherers
diminished the reliability and value of
data aggregations and one of things one
of the one of the cases that he brought
to my attention was the case of Second
World War pilots that would fly over in
order to drop bombs in Nazi held
territory and they of course were
concerned about being detected by Nazi
radar and and they came up with this
particular solution they would be flying
over towards the
target and the the radar screen would
show a phosphor dot on the screen and
all of a sudden the whole screen is full
of full of phosphor dots and what the
pilots were doing and and this was
courtesy of a journalist in in the
Netherlands who found this photograph
for us was they were releasing what was
known as radar chaff and actually Finn
had seen examples of this radar chaff in
a museum in Berlin which was simply
pieces of paper black on the one side
aluminum on the other side and as the
planes were getting into range they
would release these these this radar
chaff phosphor darts grub payload and
off they went and by the time the screen
cleared they were out of range so that
was a fascinating use of obfuscation and
here's another one who knows what this
movie is who said North by Northwest yes
good for you so where is Cary Grant I
couldn't find him here's another one
that when I was doing this research I
happen to be reading the New York Times
magazine and how many people have antes
who do that
and this one this one is an orb weaving
spider and what it does is with little
bits of of leaf and bugs that attaches
it weaves webs around it into the shape
of the orbs weaver spider itself so that
when predators are flying by they at
least increase the odds that the
predator is going to go for one of these
decoys and in case you think the orb
weaving spider is something really
exotic only found in the tropics here it
is in New Jersey and it's in my backyard
and I don't know if you can see it but
it's but it's right over there and my
family can attest that I ran outside
every few days taking pictures of this
orb weaving spider and I'm going to give
you a whole lot of other examples just
so that you get a sense of it Monroe
Washington the date was well it was in
2008 or someone robs a bank he's wearing
a blue shirt
a yellow of a yellow safety vest and
safety glasses and as after he robs the
bank he runs away the police arrive and
suddenly there dozens of men wearing
blue shirts and and yellow vests and
what he had done is he'd put an ad in
Craigslist saying there's a job here
paying a very nice salary show up at
this and this time and you must be
wearing such-and-such and he got away
this is now more recent an artist
actually Heather Dewey had had bought
bought and she's created this is real or
this is for real its DNA spray that both
erases your DNA that's one of the sprays
and replace us and what it has is has
lots of other DNA that you can if you
don't want evidence of your
prisons hopefully you're not going to
use it to conceal a crime but if for
instance you don't want anybody to know
you can you were there you can use this
Benjamin grocer has garand Oh which is
it's kind of does random emojis on
Facebook and this is Fred Cohen who in
2006 I just sort of bumped into this
article I don't know the quality of the
technical work I'd loved if anyone knows
Fred Cohen or knows about this work I
would love to hear more about it but it
was just a beautiful article about the
use of honey pots and decoys in computer
and network security and how well you
can see what you want to do really is
just change the statistical success rate
by creating decoys and diversions for
malicious attackers on a system so you
can see there's really a wide range of
of uses and formats for application so
the next project that I want to talk
about then was that nauseam we were very
happy with the way what we learned from
Trackman art and as many of us we're
concerned about whatever however you
call it surveillance capitalism
surveillance advertising targeted
behavioral advertising the need in order
to do that to track people as they as
they do everything actually now not only
what you do online but trying to match
what you do online with what your
purchases offline and so forth so this
was what we were concerned about the
advertising environment and as many
people are aware and this is a picture
that so many people will show but it
gets denser
dancer each time people show this
particular graphic but it's highly
complex real-time auctioning for ad
space that depends on a whole lot of
factors including the the person's
profile so it's targeted to the
individual and we like many privacy
advocates and activists were and
continue to be extremely we find this
activity highly problematic and as a
result we wanted to create some kind of
mechanism some kind of response and so
we created ad nauseam so here's the
little introduction as data hoarding
corporations keep sabotaging the
Constitution of the do-not-track
standard and ad networks keep selling
our profiles behind our backs we are
left with no choice but to fight back
from the studios that brought you track
via the browser extension that keeps
searching to obfuscate your search
queries comes yet another data
obfuscation pleasure
ad nauseam clicking ad so you don't have
to the ad nauseum plugin works in
concert with your favorite ad blocker
every ad block distance silently clicked
by ad nauseum confusing your data
trackers by virtually liking all ads
within your browser the ad nauseum
add-on collects and visualizes your
quick stream over time giving you a
small glimpse of the data you passively
generate an ad nauseum works in the
background and does not interfere with
your browsing
point your browser at this URL and
install ad nauseam now spread the word
and help us code as we work to make ad
nauseum better and to bring it to more
people and more browsers finally to the
ad industry we would like to say it is
time to be respectful of our privacy
expectations let's work together towards
an honest and meaningful do-not-track
standard until that day comes be sure
you will keep pushing your buttons all
of them
[Music]
[Music]
you
okay
[Applause]
so that's ad nauseum and clicks all the
ads on your screen and you this is how
you can personalize it you can hide the
ads if you like or in some of some of
the time when I use ad nauseam I I don't
hide the ads because I don't mind seeing
ads I just don't like the tracking that
goes along with them click Add sometimes
malware's delivered through the trackers
and so we also block that so there's a
fear but you can do what's also very
nice about ad nauseam is it creates an
ad vault so if you're not looking at the
ads and even if you are it creates an
aggregate of all the ads that have been
shown to you mainly the display ads but
then also just the kind of classified
looking ads on your page and it's it's
it's actually a fascinating because it
gives you a little glimpse of how how
the web or how the ad ad network
landscape is viewing you and I I saw
that I could tell from this that I enjoy
watching thrillers and and I just didn't
understand why I got so many shoe ads
because honestly anyway but it does
reveal something about yourself we have
a github we welcome people to to tell us
about bugs and for King and and so on
it's all open codon and obviously these
both track minute and ad nauseam are
free and free to download and the
Tally's question I had anticipated now
this as you and you'll see there's a
reason for these numbers this only tells
you the numbers of Firefox users and in
fact from what we can tell the majority
of our users are actually chrome users
but we we don't have statistics on
chrome use so ad nauseam cause yes
I don't think I think we don't you don't
get cookies oh you mean besides the add
cookies there is other now we don't you
don't God no I don't think you get
cookies I think we block the cookies
sorry I I didn't anticipate the question
I would have checked with the team yeah
we don't know and and yes yes right and
and you know this this is this was ad
nauseum was much more controversial let
me just say from the outset then track
me not and we we had been worried about
the click-fraud accusation and we just
we didn't think there was no money
involved we weren't generating money for
ourselves and we weren't purposely
generating I know I know but I'm we were
at some point worried would we could we
be sued for click fraud and and with
that we haven't because we ourselves are
not committing the click fraud I mean
we're here we are we gonna we gonna talk
a lot about this this is this is good
service' we had a lot of interest we're
not benefiting from the clicks the the
trouble was with words like fraud it's
it's so the ethics of it is so baked in
and and you'll see there's still going
to be a big discussion of the ethics and
so I want you I don't want to attach
fraud to it until unless we can come to
the conclusion that it's fraudulent so
here are some of the reactions these
were the positive reaction this one was
from a friendly person who decided that
he had an idea for how to extort money
using ad nauseam and we was kind of
politely said we love you enthusiasm but
no thank you we we want to stay on the
right side of the law and then there
were many negative reactions lots of
criticism and this was one of them pale
moon which is
browser I think it's an offshoot of a
Firefox browser
anyway he banned us from his browser and
and we had it we had a very long
correspondence we each tried to explain
our positions and in the end we just he
gave us a very bad rating and and that
was the end of our relationship so so
that's the fun part of the talk and now
and now comes more of the analysis of of
ad nauseam and track me not and
generally of obfuscation I went around
and I talked about track m'naghten and
ad nauseam as one might about one's
children and I was so proud and every
every place I went of course there were
there were people who loved it but there
were people who were very critical and
many of those people said that it was
unethical and some people said
absolutely it doesn't work and have you
verified and so forth and so I want to
take you through both of these questions
to show you where we are with both of
those questions and you'll see that it's
a highly complex situation and it's
unfolding and continues to unfold so
there's a lot more in this with this
question but I wanted to end with the
does it work question and get some help
from all of you so when we ask the
question is it ethical we mean and and
here David Lyon the philosopher ethicist
had coined the term court of conscience
conscience versus court of law and we're
talking about court of conscience
because there's certain answers that can
be given in about what's legal and what
isn't legal and I'm not going to be
talking about that directly so as you
can guess some of the concerns that
people raised about these of these were
a lot in regards to track me not some of
them about ad nauseam or about many of
the products that I showed you that
weren't out
- they said and in fact this was
actually the very first time I talked
about track me not in Bloomington
Indiana
and the first question that a woman
raised her hand and said this is
terrible you're lying you're deceiving
and you know I was quite taken aback and
and spent have spent a lot of time
thinking about that
some people said it's a free run your
free riding on piers and on the services
you're wasting bandwidth server server
resources you polluting the data streams
and kind of generically you're you're
causing harm now before we go anywhere I
want to say that the waste accusation I
got me angry and I want to just get rid
of it immediately
because when you use the word waste you
have an assumption of what is worthy
what uses are worthy and there's an
assumption built in that those clicks
that we were generating or those queries
that were were generated by Craig Minaj
were wasteful of bandwidth or wasteful
of server time whereas me searching
Justin Bieber you know that was
acceptable use for me looking at kittens
endlessly
you know that is a use so I decided I
don't even think there's much to argue
here because what we were trying to do
is to protect privacy and that seemed
like a good thing and so I didn't want I
didn't even want to factor this waste
question into consideration now if you
if you if you follow some kind of
systematic ethical reasoning roughly
utilitarian reasoning in order to make
an argument that some activity is just
or that it's right or defensible the
first thing you have to say first first
of all application is not in itself good
and maybe we would say it's not in
itself bad but what you want to do
initially is to make sure that the
purposes of obfuscation are just and so
it we looked at many of the cases that
we'd been studying and decided that for
example if ad nauseum is an attempt to
elude surveillance and profiling that
was a just end or if track me not is
trying to achieve intellectual freedom
so that people can inquire go after
information freely without being
concerned that they're under
surveillance promote intellectual
freedom
that's just end in the case of hardware
obfuscation which I didn't talk about
which is a technique that many chip
makers use in order to protect
intellectual property they create some
sort of fake fake circuits to protect
this intellectual property that seemed
like a just end but robbing a bank you
know obviously or fooling consumers
other uses we had to say ok that's just
no longer something that we're going to
justify and so having established that
track me not an ad nauseam in our view
were the ends were just there's still
another question that one needs to ask
which is and we all know this phrase do
the ends justify the means and one way
of looking at it is to say are there
other ways of doing this that are less
harmful are there gentle means and we
looked at some of the the predominant
possibilities Oh people would say you
could just opt out and I don't think we
can opt out this is this is we're way
too far down non-regulation have not
helped us much corporate based practice
takes us to a distance but with the
underlying model itself is problematic
technology wasn't helping us with those
particular cases that we were looking at
and so now back to this just general
idea of cause harm when you think about
causing harm or when your actions are
diminishing the interests somebody else
else's interest a question you want to
ask is do you owe it to that party not
to cause harm and this comes this this
particular phrase what we owe others
what do we owe others comes from the
philosopher and ethicist a great
philosopher and ethicist Tim Scanlon
which is that it's not sufficient to say
you're causing harm or you interfering
with it with the interest but that you
owe the person not to do that and that's
an ethical question so when you look at
Fred CO and and it was really
interesting that in Fred Cohen's the
same article he was concerned about the
fact that decoys are in a way lying to
the malicious attacker but I think we
would all agree that lying to a
malicious attacker is you don't owe the
truth to the malicious attacker if you
can provide a decoy now a very strict
Chi Thien might disagree with you and
there is you know that the the case
where the the murderer comes to a person
and says you know I want to kill Shafie
where did she go and Kant argued you
still are obligated to tell the truth
and I think that centuries of ethicists
have tried to make sense of that
particular recommendation but I just
thought I would have it you know okay so
ad nauseam coming back to that nauseam
it caused a stir at the time and it was
more controversial and three years after
we released that it was banned so this
is February 2017 but I don't know if you
can read it but the reason given
is that we have a single-purpose policy
and we consider your extensions
functionality that blocks malware to be
a distinct purpose from the function
which hides and clicks ads to have your
item reason stated we suggest
restricting the extension to a single
functionality so we were puzzled by this
because we didn't think that blocking
malware should be considered as a kind
of an additional thing that we should
actually remove that functionality and
then our software would be accepted but
nevertheless and we and this actually
you can see is is is not the very first
communication and we kept on trying to
adjust the system adjusted back and
forth back and forth no such like so we
had some good publicity out of that and
and and yet you know I was troubled and
and and I was troubled by what we were
doing with ad nauseam because I think
people raised some important questions
so I decided to look at you know do a
big search on what other extensions and
apps had been banned from the chrome
store
well the chrome store and and also the
Play Store and here was one the windows
chrome extensions and then Microsoft
retaliated and disconnect was another
one that was banned which blocks
non-consensual third-party data
collectors that monitor uses when they
surf this was these two were also banned
these were independent app stores
aptoide is a Portuguese independent app
store and this was banned from the Play
Store gab is a is a social network that
as you see is used by the alt-right so
it it it was banned stylish was
essentially spyware
people downloaded thinking it was one
thing but actually it did very bad
things on on your on your browser and
here Gizmodo had talked about it fake ID
apps were banned and then finally you
have these malicious cryptocurrency
mining extension and that in the
background are using your system to to
mine cryptocurrency so where did we fall
in all of this like I don't know if we
were in such a good company
so some of the companies seemed okay to
us and in thinking about it I they seem
to be three groups one was a group of
apps and extensions that we could just
say do bad things the other one are
absent extensions that are conduits or
mediate mediators of bad things
and the third one were simply absent
extensions that conflict with Google's
interests and I want to say oh this
happened to be with Google but I want to
like generalize and talk about platforms
generally because I don't think this is
a Google only question and when I went
back to the apps and extensions that
these this is how I classified them the
first are you know societal stand a
fickle standards you had community
standards and then you have interests so
we back to the Tim Scanlan question of
what do we owe and I wanted to look at
the second one and and say okay you know
Google Facebook and so on they've they
take the high ground and they and
they're getting rid of gab but what have
we learnt in the past few years that as
mediators of bad things this ad model
has allowed the fake news that has
threatened our democracies target people
searching racist phrases
of course Facebook similar similar
concerns this model also provides honey
honey pots for for folks who want data
and then finally this too which was
recently reported in the news so let's
come back to this and say you know where
do we stand
and finally after some back-and-forth we
got an answer from Michael fell goosed
who is with Google and and and now the
story was different and even though we
had solved some of the other problems
we're still not compliant and we're not
going to be reinstated and what it says
here is that sending automated clicks in
such a way but they may result in
financial harm to third-party systems
such as advertising networks and so I
wondered about this because you don't
you don't want your your product to have
sorry
be a sec to harm innocent bystanders
that was the that was the phrase that I
wanted to think of so I did a little bit
of research and and this is I don't know
what you can see here but but this is
this is the proportion of of ad networks
that are present on the web and to say
that we're harming third parties I think
is a little bit disingenuous so I want
you to say I mean in its you know maybe
with setting humility aside that ad
nauseam belongs in this third category
so we have apps and extensions that
compete with the platform's interest and
and that's what they are now that in
itself and you know blah blah here are a
couple of things but how do we resolve
these conflicts in society the story is
not over by the way yes
might get charged for that that is that
was has been an argument like the pale
moon argument but it wasn't the argument
it was third party systems such as
advertising network so I was only
speaking to that and it is the case that
ad nauseam does cause people who have
tracking ads on their websites to pay
money even though the ad being clicked
is clicked by it it you know it's it's
whoever the ad network is but it does
harm the party places that and this is
probably the most troubling things
the thing about ad nauseam but what we
what we have is we have a white list a
white listing capacity and we give users
the choice and we actually advise as a
default that that we don't click the
white listed ads which are non tracking
ads so all right so this is where we put
ourselves and where this puts us is in a
in a complex situation
think about Microsoft versus Google in
that situation
think about ad nauseam trying to
struggle in one way and Google is
providing a service and what we're doing
conflicts with the business model and I
think there's no end to the story in the
sense that well the end of the story is
we if you have Chrome on a Windows
machine you there's a way to install ad
nauseam on your computer if you have a
Mac then you and you use Chrome you're
out of luck you cannot and that's why we
don't have to
two sticks for Chrome yes although in
the first three years the chrome use was
was way more than the Firefox use so
what we have is an ongoing debate in
society where we who are trying to
defend privacy are saying the laws are
not strong enough we need to have a way
to defend ourselves we need some way
because what kept on happening with the
do-not-track standard was that industry
would just like at some point get up and
walk out the room if you don't have a
bargaining chip on the other side you've
got no way to achieve the goal you need
on the other hand you do need to make
just steak or your claim on the moral
high ground and I think that many of the
platforms are trying to show that what
they're doing is also on this moral high
ground and that their interests are
actually compatible with social
interests and I say the court of laws no
help because we don't yet have good laws
privacy laws I don't know how I'm doing
on time but I could be going on
I've got about five minutes left right
yeah what oh yes I know but Tully wanted
yes okay okay
hold hold the thought I want I want to
answer that but let me try and just get
through a little bit of this part which
is going to be my yes yes yes okay good
does it work and you'll see that it does
it work as well as it could and the
answer is I don't know no the answer is
it depends so let me let me take you
back to track me not for a moment
because this is the situation that we're
in with track me not here we were I'm
saying oh my god I don't want search
engines to monitor me I don't want them
to store I don't want them to profile I
don't want to feel self-conscious when I
look up you know cure for herpes I know
I don't want to feel that this is going
into some record that that you know that
that I'll have to account for that's not
what a free society does so what do I do
I go to my government and I said do
something about this protect me nothing
I go to the search engine company who do
I write to and it's like we have
actually had some meetings over the
years and there has been some progress
like after X number of years we're going
to remove a number you know you're the
last such-and-such numbers of the IP
address so you know there won't be so
much linking basically no help so
there's only one way to get in
can you see I don't know this is a door
so this one way you can get the search
engine to respond to you and what's that
you submit a search who said that
good you submit a search so that's like
the vector that's the point of entry and
that's was how we decided that's how
we're gonna do it with track me not
that's our point of entry and Gary marks
who was a very early theorist he's the
sociologist of social implications of
digital technology has a book and also
an article in this book it's attacking
the shoe neutralizing and resisting the
new surveillance he he had this
beautiful observation that one way that
people the weaker party in a certain
relationship can defend themselves is
you find a blind spot that's inherent in
a large-scale system and this this felt
to us like a beautiful account of what
we were doing with office gation and
Fred Cohen observes a little bit
plaintively that you can never be done
whatever you're doing can't be done
definitively with our tremendous
intelligence capability so when you ask
you know does it work or oh sorry and
and I wanted you to see this particular
use of obfuscation which was used during
the McCrone you know after the whole
concern about Russian hackers during the
elections in France macrons team had
used these kinds of decoys to obfuscate
attacks so when we come back now to this
question of desert work and I call
friendly fire Catarina
you because I've had a lot of arguments
I won't mention with whom about why you
know why data obfuscation is
just arbitrary and it's haphazard and
can you verify the impact in the answers
we don't have the intelligence I mean we
okay so it didn't come out right but we
don't have insight into what's going on
on the other side because these are
wholly opaque and transparent systems
and so we've done some testing we've
salts on the side channel problems but
we don't know can they find and throw
out the fake queries if if so maybe the
cost is too great we we're interested in
you know some statistical success can
they identify people using Trackman art
I think they could if if they looked at
the particular terms but can they do it
on scale we don't know I think not and
does it matter and now with machine
learning
maybe the fake queries are even
irrelevant so with that nauseum you know
we go through the whole argument yeah
they can tell you using AG nauseam so
what do what do we do we just throw your
data out well that success so what we
decide about it and now we're getting
this is now very close to the end is
that when you talk about success with
that with obfuscation you really need to
talk about what the aims are it's never
this global theoretic success that you
might want with other theoretical
approaches sometimes you just want to
buy a little bit of time so if you're
flying over and you release the chaff
you know that at some point the chaps
disappearing and there's only a phosphor
dot but you've had enough time to drop a
bomb and fly away sometimes it's just to
provide cover or prevent individual
exposure or to interfere with profiling
not to prevent identification but to
interfere with the profile they have of
you they may know it's you but
make mistakes about what you are and
sometimes it's just to express proof
protest there are certain requirements
that people may have of their systems
do we want it to be stealth or do we do
do we not care whether they know that
we're office gating is it short term or
long term selectable general you know do
we want alpha skate to the whole world
or just to targeted individuals who's
the adversary is it just my nosy
neighbor or is it the NSA is a powerful
person is it rich how determined are
they how much are they willing to throw
at the problem these are all factors
that are going to determine whether your
system works so I would like to see a
science of data obfuscation but it can't
be too general because there too many
dimensions we need to take the aims we
need to know what the requirements are
and maybe acquire some systematic
knowledge recently John very recently a
couple of weeks ago Jonathan's the trend
had said that and and more vital today
then at its launch years ago and
Shoshana Zubov continues to be concerned
about what she and especially in her
recent book surveillance capitalists are
the envy of every state security agency
I think data obfuscation has a powerful
potential it is could be scary needs to
pass the test of ethics but it also
needs to be safeguarded and these the
this is what we need to safeguard
ethical data obfuscation and I'm going
to end and I'm going to just leave that
the slide here because I've now spoken
for long enough and
[Applause]
microphones that all pass around right
here should I wait fool yeah you can
tell us what you think about encrypted
messaging apps like whatsapp or signal
in terms of for example with whatsapp
whatsapp is on my Facebook they claim
that their messages are end-to-end
encrypted so that what's happening
Facebook can't read them but the we
don't necessarily trust what Facebook
tells us and so do you have like any
ideas for potentially office gating
messages like sending fake messages over
there yeah yeah that's a great question
in that and and I was running out of
time and I wasn't able to kind of dwell
on this question of a threat model
because many of the colleagues in the in
the privacy program are working on
something called differential privacy
and that requires in many instances a
collaboration so with with what so with
whatsapp and I don't know you you're
getting a service that's saying that
it's in turn encrypted and and it's even
encrypted from the provider of that
service if you feel comfortable that
that provider can't verify this fact
with you then you you know this is great
but the cases that I was talking about
with obfuscation were cases where the
where you have an adversarial
relationship with that provider so I
can't answer your question about
Facebook and the details of it because I
don't have enough knowledge of that
relationship but what I can say is that
different solutions in the privacy space
we really need to bring to the fore
what the threat model is what is the
nature of the adversarial model because
in some cases certain solutions will
work but in other cases you might need
to use a facin which arguably is a less
somewhat weaker solution
a privacy solution and when I say we
come in more vulnerable and and maybe
more messy yeah thank you
so I want to come back to the question
of whether it works and I'll make an
educated guess that it doesn't why is
that because click-fraud is a giant
problem of the Internet it's one of the
ways of monetizing what networks so any
advertising systems worth their salt
deploy a very sophisticated sophistica
technologies to filter out throttle
click clicks clicks so my assumption is
that the clicks generated by ad nauseum
will be filtered out filtered out
immediately without reaching the back
ends of the advertising systems so
Katrina ask whether ad nauseum gives
people like a false sense of security I
would rephrase it whether it gives them
a false sense of protest the protest but
amin here's does it concern you why did
we get banned
yeah well it's it it does impose a cost
on unsophisticated advertisers so any
rail system won't notice that because
like the number of kick throws of
fraudulent leaks is like in its I
believe it's like it was estimated more
than ten percent it's giant so I don't
think it at nauseam imposed a
significant cost um I'm open to show me
you know what I'm saying is I am happy
to have this conversation show me that
it works show me that it doesn't work
but show me how this system works so
that I can verify the right method to
use to protect myself against it and and
I think that I have a lot of reason to
believe that you you have better
knowledge in this case then then I do
but that that's part of the conversation
that we want to have yeah so you're
asking like do I feel bad that that
users know because I think that the the
what people can do is they can not click
on as if they don't want that particular
vector of information to be going to the
ad networks or they could protest and
and I like the fact that they're
protesting
yes okay it's not it's a I guess it's
not so much a question it's maybe an
observation I'm trying to figure out why
we would have to protect the rights and
the goals of a Google or of an
unsuspecting poorly sort of formed third
party that does is very unsophisticated
versus like our personal me and what I
want so I do understand that probably
when I sign up for my goop I go into
Google somewhere it says if you agree to
use our service then we agree to collect
and then that's what you're paying by
giving a soak but what we really don't
want you to do is just do all this
fraudulent clicking around because I
don't really mess up our goals right but
if my goal is just to basically look for
things I just want to know like what are
my rights as a user in the space and is
it okay because we live in a capitalist
world right is it okay that on the
capital the capital earning the sort of
rent taking side yes more rights than me
right so we're still looking for ways to
protect but we individuals who are using
service and is the society say yeah but
see they have more money and they're
providing you the service so they have
got more rights than you is that is that
the were the balances um the current
situation is somewhat akin to what
you're saying I'm not about the money
part or anything but the current system
that we have is that organizations or
service providers have a privacy but
have a policy I don't even want to grant
it the term privacy policy they have a
policy that explains to you and nobody
reads it and we don't understand it and
like we so many people have already said
that and then if you use the service
then you've agreed to those terms so
that's why I said don't want to get
involved in the in the legality question
because it's legal that's the system the
EU has tried to to do something about it
but I'm not
where that is gonna need us so these
efforts there was there was a period of
time where privacy advocates tried to
expand what users could do by creating
something called the Do Not Track
standard where you could flip a switch
on your brother that as you went from
place to place said I don't want to be
tracked and there all these third-party
trackers that come on board when you
visit various website and that this
could have been a standard that
everybody adopted and respected but it
it there were years of discussion and
every time it got to some point that the
ad advertisers and ad networks didn't
like they walked out of the room and
this happened a few times so the answer
is we haven't made progress what we're
trying to say is that we need to give
some you know when you add a bargaining
table you need some chips and if you
don't have chips you can't do anything I
mean I I respect what you're the
challenge that this these three people
are making so help me make better
obfuscation programs ones that work
better you know no but you know this one
a couple of hands at the back and this
and this son and this someone over him I
just wanted to make two comments
the DuckDuckGo search engine says they
don't keep your logs yeah and also EF f
has privacy badger which you can stop
the tracking cookies if you want but it
will break some websites good no so we
and I just want to mention that those
are available if people are interested I
personally use DuckDuckGo and I get
better results than from Google that's
surprising I find that they're well I
mean the results are actually more on
target to what I'm looking for I also
use DuckDuckGo
but I also used track me not
okay yeah it was just you didn't mention
them and I thought yeah thank you
and and the other their other approaches
like tor is another approach that people
can use that that are even more
comprehensive hi so I've noticed that
and vertically a few more shops within a
year have stopped accepting cash
can you see sort of a data obfuscation
so we know what are the problems for
which obfuscation is the solution and
there's certain interactions that I
don't think office Keshan is the
solution to when you go to your
physician don't obfuscate you know but
society has been very clever so in those
cases where you're supposed to not
obfuscate we try and have a backstop
where we impose some confidentiality
requirements and in the financial arena
in particular because I think I mean
that's the way I view it because of this
kind of need to be very precise and to
keep records we do happen to have
regulation now what you're saying this
this massive change in the financial
arena and company and the way the
regulation works and you know I'm I'm
not getting a little carried away
because this is like another thing which
is the way the regulation works in the
United States for these sectoral privacy
rules is that you identify who the
service provider is like you might say
these are financial actors and it's
according to the definition of those
financial actors that they are subject
to those privacy regulations there's
been an entry of all sorts of different
actors into the health space into the
into the education space into the
financial space and many of them are not
covered by those sectoral regulations so
we're in trouble
that's all I can say because I don't
think office keishon I can't think of
obfuscation as a solution to that what
do you think about like we see these
products as free a lot of time like
Google but reality yeah and is I think
there's a follow-up to one of the prior
questions kind of you know they have to
charge something you know their company
yeah and you know it's not not just
legally but morally you know you're
you're giving up your privacy in your
rights to you know keep that data
private in order to use their their
services for free
mm-hm and it seems a little bit immoral
to kind of deny that um how about this
you walk into a store and you pick up a
shirt and you hand your credit card and
the company says let's not talk price
when you get home you'll see how much I
charged you well maybe you'll never know
how much I charged you so when we're
talking the problem with this particular
and you write this is really a big
systemic problem is that we don't know
the value of it and we we just don't
have it insight into it and so there are
people now who are suggesting different
kinds of models but I don't think
there's an obligation to hand a blank
check just in general there's a lot of
companies and sectors that kind of
collect data you know not just private
companies but governments to from
cameras all throughout cities yeah and I
think most recently I heard about like
gas stations right there's such a
massive network of gas station cameras
that are now being connected to each
other to analyze people as they come to
leave in their trends where do you like
how do you draw the line between all
these different sectors of like what you
should and should not do you know where
do you say no that's
yeah great question
those are and and its really take
science into the big space of privacy
and what the extent of the right is and
what it means and so on and I don't
think I have enough time to uh Chris
it's a great question and you should
keep asking it and you should try and do
something about it because at the moment
the way we regulate society we don't
have the right the people who are in
charge of regulating these activities
don't really seem to understand the
ramifications and so by the time we do
catch up we're going to be in trouble so
people should remain active and engaged
I just wanted to suggest a way to test
if it works you could click selectively
on some ads for example thriller ads and
then see if you have a different set of
ads being suggested to you if you click
them through the ad nauseum you're
saying ways to test to test the efficacy
so you just click selectively and see if
it changes there you get do and then yes
what an awesome is a wild success even
as a provocation on getting Google
support to have to respond even if it
does absolutely nothing to that networks
or or for free users question is I
thought when energy was mentioned on the
ethical slide I think we're going to
talk about the additional pollution
required by running it on your computer
versus an ad blocker and I wonder if you
have any idea what the energy
consumption is relative to an ad blocker
Wow
yeah I know but and in fact that
question has been raised I don't know
but so hard to know what the comparison
point would be when you think about
different people's their levels of usage
yeah yeah it's yeah right
and what if it did what it what if it
did it was incrementally more the the
point about the waste is whether you
deem a certain used to be a use or a
waste so when there when there's a draft
people in Northern California really
grumble because people in Southern
California are busy were watering their
lawns with the water and the north thing
so that's a waste of water
you know they deem it a waste of water
but maybe having a shower is not a way
you know so so it's it's part of the
judgment if I'm saying I'm defending my
privacy then I don't see it as a waste I
see it as a good use but I appreciate
your question I mean I'm not sure I had
two questions concerns actually one was
just raised about the energy usage
especially if what you know these
add-ons become widespread and then
everybody is running one and it becomes
sort of like a large-scale yeah nickel
take track me not everybody's using us
for example right yeah dream come true
and what are they what are the
indications of that energizer it could
be substantial it on that scale
but my second concern was actually the
in the other scenario where only a few
people are using something like that so
there have been multiple uses of search
query information by law enforcement in
particular that was used as evidence
where people would be searching for
something sinister online and that would
add to
the you know the additional evidence
collected and then some people were
convicted of crimes based on the
searches now in the do-not-track
scenario you are randomly sampling and
replicating those searches so I wondered
whether how do not track handles this a
situation where somebody could be
unfairly accused of potentially
committing a crime based on or whatever
you know maybe it's not a crime but but
some some kind of suspicion may arise
based on those randomly generated
searches that that system generates yeah
yeah
and this can by the way in terms of like
I said of my dream come true but but but
it seems to me that if a lot of people
are using some of these I think the
services and the companies would be
savvy to that and they would see that so
many people are interested in something
actually wider so what we've said in our
various publications about at nauseam
about Trackman art is we don't think of
obfuscation as the the end solution the
end solution is good regulation in
society that takes it so you remember I
said like these conflicting interests
and what do we do to resolve them we
need regulators who are going to look at
that and it gets to your question Amy
also and come up with good regulation
obfuscation for the most part especially
ours is just an interim solution and and
the signal that we're getting the more
people use it and we're way tiny I'm
completely accept that but if more
people are Bennett sending a signal
about popular resistance but your other
point your other point is a very
important point and it's the difference
between a free society and a not free
society so the most important thing
about a free society is that we resist
these dragnet kinds of searches if
someone is accused of sign and we also
think intellectually we value
intellectual freedom as part of
the the first amendment and when we do a
dragnet we may you know we just don't
accept dragnet searches if there's some
if you're under stress under suspicion
for some other reason and then we decide
we're going to search your search
queries then perhaps that provides some
additional evidence but we you know we
just if we become that society where we
we're gonna do a general search on what
people are searching then we're no
longer a free society so I that doesn't
bother me so much though I accept that
there could be that consequence
piggybacking on what one of the people
was asking up there before at first I
just wanted to say I I feel very
strongly about privacy issues online so
I really appreciate what you're focused
on and the whole idea of this basically
being a foot in the door it's not an
answer but it's a way to stick the foot
in the door and say hey let's try and
crack this door open so we have a
bargaining chip so that they're actually
listening in some way one of the things
that's tricky in terms of piggybacking
the comments earlier about the financial
piece is unlike the medical environment
with HIPAA where you do have the privacy
we are or health insurance providers are
actually paying the doctors in this
situation the search engines
it's totally run by ads so there's it
almost seems like there needs to be some
kind of option where if you or I want
the service we get to pay for it mm-hm
just like when I go on iTunes because I
don't feel like watching ads when I want
to see one particular 30-minute program
and if I want to watch it for free okay
I'll suck it up and I'll watch the
different ads that's a choice I get
right in a search choice I don't get
that and duck taco I have not had that
positive restaurants yeah well so so I'm
so pleased you asked that question
because none of what I have done
contrary to ads and in fact I use ad
nauseam with show me the ads switched on
just not the tracking and there was a
time and it wasn't even that long ago
where online you know online services
offered contextual ads which is and and
they weren't even random they were they
were ads that were related to if you
went to a clothing you know what
whatever store you went toward it
whatever website it would be related to
kind of generally understood and it's
only as far as I'm understanding to get
a like a delta increase in revenues that
we have an entire surveillance mechanism
on the web in order to service that
little extra bit
so if advertising is going to support a
website I don't mind
some people are annoyed by advertising
they use ad blockers but I would accept
that as as an exchange the part that all
of this resists is the surveillance I
don't know how we doing on time you
should tell me when I start when I
should stop
okay one one last question last question
what about mobile a lot of the the worst
privacy invasions are asking on these
devices
yeah and the younger generation isn't
using laptops anymore they yeah they
live on mobile right well so and and
we've had these conversations a lot one
of the troubles with mobile I think it's
a trouble the companies don't think it's
the trouble is that the systems are much
more closed and so where is there's a
lot that we can see in the web because
it has these open protocols the the
mobile operating systems are much more
buttoned down you know this was
something Jonathan Citroen wrote about
many years ago maybe not enough people
paid attention to him but I think that
reality is there now you can generate
apps and we're talking about
transitioning some of these as apps onto
the mobile environment but I'm not sure
that I'm not sure how they'll translate
but it's a great point
[Applause]